okay I have like a relationship in order
of size so I'm going to do something a
little extra mm-hmm 10x right it's an
abbreviation it's an identity for a
relationship between two other trig
ratios that are more basic
what's that relationship sign on college
right okay now this is gonna look a
little like where did this come from but
stay with me for a second I wanted to
see how like from this line to this line
I saw all look this half r-squared thief
no just half a squared is 1/2 1/2
squared coming up again and again I'm
gonna divide through by that okay well I
noticed that this is there's this sign X
also coming up in two spots so even
though there isn't one in the middle
I'm going to divide by it anyway okay
now I'm gonna ask the question again
from this line to this line I asked you
about the direction of the inequality
and I said did it change your answer was
no I'm allowed to divide through by sine
X which it's also variable like R is so
will the direction of my inequality
change you have to think about this one
about divide divide through by sine well
the direction change now the answer is
no let's write down what we get and then
we'll explain why when you divide this
by sine X you get 1 when you divide this
you get this fraction when you divide
this you get you get 1 over cos right
which is um I suppose you could write as
SEC X if you wanted to but for reasons
that will become clear in about 45
seconds there's no reason why now why is
true that I don't have to muck around
with the direction in the inequality
it's because what kind of X's am i
interested in I'm interested in small X
right well for small X like really tiny
values of X what is the sign what's the
sine of sine and the answer is it's
positive all the trig ratios are
positive for small values of X because
the first quadrant right so that's okay
so I can say you know since X okay
now to formally talk about this because
hopefully you feel slightly awkward
about using this very informal way I
like small X what does that even mean
we have language we have notation for
talking about when things get really
small what is that language when
something gets closer and closer and
closer to zero we would say we would say
I'm going to get close to the origin but
I have like special language to do with
when things get really little remember
its limits right so I'm gonna take the
limit of every single thing as X gets
really small that would be as X
approaches zero so let's do it the limit
as X approaches zero of this will be
less than the limit as X approaches zero
of this which is less than the limit as
X approaches zero of this okay again a
poorly designed board sorry a bit of a
theme of my work as you can see I think
you're okay with this diagram you've
probably got it down well and truly now
so it's going to disappear I want you to
see something it's so cool in this in
this line here that it's really bizarre
and it has a funny name to go with it
okay humor me when X approaches zero
what happens to the number one the
answer is nothing this is independent of
X he doesn't care what X is doing X
could be turning into a rockmelon
it would still be one okay so on the
left hand side that one is just one in
the middle I have this weird thing I'm
gonna come back to this in a minute I
don't know what to do with this just yet
I'm just gonna put it there just like I
had it written before what how does the
right hand limit what happens to this
guy what is cos x doing when X gets
small the answer is it approaches one
you know what the graph looks like here
is his cause right and no matter whoops
no matter which side you approach from
when you get towards zero as an x value
coming towards one for the the whole
graph right so this is becoming 1 over 1
well I'm pretty sure I know what
everyone is right it's now this guy here
this cute little
project I kid you not this is actually
rather small X being Logan is that the
proper way to say it the proper way to
call like what this situation is is
called this is this actual name the
squeeze law some people to make it sound
more formal call it the squeeze theorem
but in fact it's it's squeezed and they
just make you laugh so what's going on
what's going on well see this X over
sine X thing right well it's got to be
bigger than one it also has to be
smaller than one there's nothing else it
can do it must be one right does that
make sense so if you're if you're sort
of constrained and squeezed between
these two boundaries that are the same
boundary then I can infer therefore the
limit as X approaches zero of this thing
equals one doesn't just get close to one
it actually is one it's constrained from
both sides okay now what does this mean
well this shows me that sine X and X
when you take the ratio between these
two things when you compare them when
you divide one by the other they they
get closer and closer to being identical
that's what a ratio of one means yeah if
it's one to one we have the same amount
of whatever stuff we're talking about
okay now I'm gonna leave it as an
exercise to you to try and work out how
can I come up with a similar sort of
argument using all the same foundation
we've just set up to show that X and tan
X also do the same thing they also the X
divided by tan X or tan X divided by X
it all goes toward one because the
reciprocal of 1 is 1 so you could turn
these upside down or we'd still work out
quite nicely okay so the last thing I'm
going to do is just show you because
some of the questions will ask you
things like this what happens when these
things don't quite match up so just as
an example what if I have the limit as X
approaches zero we'll do a simple one
first of two X on sine X now that's not
excellent sine X is it but it's so very
close what can I do with this to make
that look like what I just used what I
just established yeah
I can factorize the two out russ was
exactly right because just like he are
the one is independent of X that two is
also independent back it doesn't care
right so I can bring it at the front
like so and then say everything else is
exactly the same X on assign X but I
know what this is equal to I just proved
it right so this is 2 times 1 I'm gonna
ask I'm gonna insist on you actually
writing the 1 there and not just saying
too because it indicates I've just done
something with this object it
contributes nothing in terms of
multiplication but I it's it's equal to
something okay so that's equal to 2 what
about if I changed it to be this X on
sine of X what would you do with that
cuz again they don't match hmm I want
the top on the bottom to have the same
angle right I want them both be going
small X they're not the same right now
can I change this easily like can I just
factor out the 1/2 I can't write because
sine closed hand trig functions aren't
as easy and neat as that so if I can't
change this easily maybe I should change
the top one right well it's quite easy
to turn that into a half even though
it's not right now if for example I put
a half there you can't just multiply
things but because you want to write but
I can balance something out that would
give me the same result right I would
put it two at the front because two
times 1/2 is is the original question
yeah that's what you started with so
that's also equal to 2 because now
there's a 1/2 X there 1/2 X there it's
fine okay